what's up this is Fitness it and this is
actually me let's go to Instagram if you
were to sum up just looking two words
what would it be
stupid fresh Superfly what is this that
Kanye West fresh for descent album sales
beef was legendary [ __ ] was like the
presidential race for the both in their
prime
we all got I should have taught in the
US after that cuz that was his first
record they really impacted nine already
so huge in Oscar records I was like I'm
sick of the United States I'm going over
I was a Costa for Croatia goodbye in the
water Africa I was opening new markets
at my let's go to Yahoo Answers it's
just 50 cent really on vitamin water no
I don't know I don't is 50 cent to make
it no
after making relatives let's go to
Twitter it's 50 cent cool with Rob
Kardashian okay I was just showing Rob
some compassion you know I'm saying and
I was telling them his point confusion I
[ __ ] with hose to at a different point
in my life so I was just identifying
with him so he did y'all poking up about
his dealings with like China posted
after the sister has a bullet fragment
and his tongue for when he was shot nine
times in 2000 this is correct in the
photograph you can see where my teeth
was knocked out on that side of my my
facebook shot
I wonder if I made 50 cents a there you
know I love you like a fat kid loves
cake and 21 questions I always crack up
every time I hear that that was I want
you to see what I'm saying
I say things I use ik at points what I'm
trying to say to you is I love you put
too much you use no good for me see you
ain't thinking about that like that
alright say decoding lyrics right here
yes
how many cars this 50 cent had 550 ain't
got no Bugatti I want no cars it costs
as much as planes that I can't find
nobody who want to buy it from me when I
get ready to get rid of it this 50 cent
Illuminati if I was a woman I'd be
nominated for something whatnot I'd have
some kind of [ __ ] nominations I can't
even
who is Illuminati let me call them and
talk to them about this [ __ ] maybe they
can get somebody to do me a favor
what does take you to the candy shop me
it means I take you to the hotel
cleaning version answered wah wah wah
wah calm what was 50 cent like growing
up and my interesting upbringing I was
actively involved in things kids are not
supposed to be involved and what wait if
it changed hiphop mixtape forever I
actually put songs in song format like I
made mixtapes
2000 stuff like that but I put it in
some format so now when the artist says
yeah check out my mixtape 90% of the
time the only doing that because I did
that in the past it resulted in the
largest debut at hip hop because I was
able to showcase the songwriting ability
and doing it that way so it's cool cool
fun facts how can I achieve of zj4
descent well you know this physique over
here buddy is a reflection of discipline
commitment all you gotta do is work out
sometime I work out sometime
let's go to you two
[Music]
she worked it make me wonder how did he
get fifty with him oh this is Keenan
Cahill we did the little collaboration
for the song called down on me with
Jeremiah and it went to number one true
story
how about some ready 50 cent aluminum
was offered see you again song on Fast &
Furious 7 but they refused that was in I
was involved in that you respond
submitted let's go to Wikipedia
corporate positions do unity foundation
i NC founder SMS Audio CEO founder SK
Energy founder SMS promotion CEO founder
yes enough I had a new spirits companies
I experience so enough said
let's go back to Twitter 50 cent did not
acts a whole 21 crunches all 21
questions and we haven't done a good job
of holding them accountable
this guy can't actually count very well
21 questions has 21 questions just got
to go back and count them let's fit this
it dropped on his video game bulletproof
tool I'm not sure the title be
bulletproof tool but I a new video game
coming shortly ask so many new ideas and
concepts that I'm getting ready to start
talks to develop cent or the pair junior
June still haven't come this was in 2011
that's [ __ ] up the instinct um since
2011 shouldn't notify someone man it's
like it's a long time right when is
power coming back on be back on shortly
but you got a quite opportune calling
optimum and tell them you want your
power submit
let's go to imdb.com there's some
personal quotes from IMDB it says I'm
not trying to save the world as a
musician and artist did you say me man
becomes as attractive as an attractive
woman when he become successful and its
publicly known it powers aphrodisiac
new quote I'm a narcissist right and I
don't care how you feel
coat me right now when I want to go
somewhere trigger section oh I got new
information for you ready my favorite
movie at the present moment is dinner
thieves it's my movie to our Butler's in
it check it out I'm a superstar I'm
gonna be a big activation like that my
favorite food turkey cheese it's really
basic but Turkey in Jesus it for me
right now that's enough for nailing that
for today I think I answered enough
questions see y'all later
you shoulda saw his expression that was
priceless he said what